how many people here have used chat GPT
RNA I think I don't think people realize
that Alexa and Google home and apple
home are about to use this for real for
real I don't think people realize it's
going to look like this hey Alexa I have
six of my son's friends coming over two
are lactose intolerant one is vegan
three are a mess and I'd like them to
eat it and I'd like them to eat a little
healthier
I only have a couple hundred bucks in
budget and they'll be here for about
four or five hours but I also need
something quick and snacky in the
morning because they're gonna sleep over
and I want to send them home with
something send it that's how people are
gonna shop so what I just said is real
life in five seven nine ten years